all right should everybody buckle up
and be ready for christmas how are you
feeling
i am feeling ready to do this i've been
wanting to do this for so long
it's been a long time right why do you
think now
was the perfect time for another
long-awaited all-star season
uh i i don't know well one because
what's happening in the world
we need big brother and we need to
understand that
we like there's perseverance in this in
cbs you know and they're going to bring
back
some familiar faces that america fell in
love with
and and mix it up i think everybody's
been asking for an all-star season for
years and i'm just so thankful and
grateful
that it is this year because i think one
we need it more than ever before and two
i'm actually able to participate this
year
i mean how badly do you want to get this
win
uh it's not even a measure of want it's
it's just gonna happen it's
like it's not a question it's an answer
i mean if anybody knows
anything about me they know that i am
just tenacious
when i set myself up for goal that i
just go
at it and i mean i've done some really
really extraordinary things in my life
and this is one of them and this is no
different i'm gonna go all the way
so you're not even questioning that
you're gonna
win how are you gonna win i am
i'm gonna do whatever it takes uh you
know i
i am loyal to god myself
my son and my family and going into that
house you play by a
separate set of rules than you do in
life and i didn't really
understand that completely last time and
you know
my son's name is loyal and i'm loyal to
him so i'm gonna go in there and do
whatever is necessary
does that mean maybe you won't be loyal
uh to everybody in the house that i have
an alliance with
not if i don't not if i don't need to
all right
looks like you are ready to hold nothing
back and
do whatever it takes as you said what if
whatever it takes includes breaking
another boat don't touch it don't touch
it
oh man
can i break like a pinky bone or
something because i didn't break one i
broke ten
so i feel like that gets me a pass for
this season
like no more books
[Laughter]
oh no i don't i mean i mean i i'd do it
i guess
i don't want to manifest it i don't want
to speak it into existence
but there will be a deep irony if you
sustain another injury
yes well listen bones heal glorious
forever
good motto i like that that's your motto
heading in yes
um how will it feel to be able to play
the game
without hopefully an injury will that
change the way that you do things
i don't know how it's going to feel
because i broke my foot
into 10 bones in day 13
day 13 and i was in there 92 days so i'm
not quite sure how it's going to feel i
really am excited to be able to
experience the full
full throttle of big brother with every
competition that i can get into
and hopefully really kind of dominate a
little bit more this time
what was your son's reaction to mom
going off and doing this
so he's 21 months and so he just blew me
kisses
and said go go go go that's amazing
how will it affect you to be away from
him he's super little will you be
emotionally on edge just being a parent
away from their child
i yeah absolutely i believe so um i've
been really trying to mentally prepare
myself for this and i had to sit down
and have a real conversation with myself
before i accepted this and i'm grateful
that i did because i have a lot to prove
to myself
and you know hopefully that proves
something to america that i am
a worthy of contender of bb all-stars
but i
i'm gonna have to take one day at a time
we have the same anklet
and so like we have the same little
bracelet on our ankle
and i just know that he is going to
flourish and
and be seeing me on tv so as long as he
gets to see me and i get to blow him
kisses
then then i'll be okay i'll know that
he's he's watching me
well you could potentially be away for a
while uh who's keeping an eye on him
while you're gone
so he's staying with his dad in florida
and
you know there was some news about us a
couple
years ago um
and and you know things happen people
disagree
and um from there we both took some time
for ourselves
and really looked at our son and really
have been working together in a
very beautiful very productive and
healthy happy way
to co-parent loyal together and so it's
kind of bizarre we're like
we we literally share each other's homes
when we when he visits
and we have a very close relationship
because of loyal
yeah that's that's growth you know that
all we can do is
ever hope to grow and change and evolve
and learn from our past um
how did he feel when when you gave him
that news and said look i've got this
opportunity
and and can you take a loyal and will he
be watching
he he's going to be watching he's going
to have loyal
playing rewinds because he doesn't stay
up that late
and he first thing he said he said you
absolutely this is a
once in a lifetime opportunity and
you're getting it twice
there's no way that you can say no and
so he's been very very supportive
and just really really wonderful for
this whole process
that is so great to hear um i guess i
also have to ask then
are you single right now could we see a
showmance bloom
ugh i get creeped out by show dances
i do it's just like i mean millions of
people are watching you
and i understand the chemistry in the
house i do
uh we saw that in my season specifically
with cody and jessica
that was undeniable not great game but
great chemistry uh i'm not interested in
a showmance i'm interested
in you know doing what i need to do to
get to the final
i mean i'm with you and i love the way
you're going in there and where your
focus is at
but we can't deny that big brother has
literally produced
marriages marriages with kids like real
relationships is it totally off the
table or do you never say never
uh i you know it's totally off the table
for me i i definitely believe
that people come together and they they
form this undeniable relationship
you know i'm still friends with uh
several people from my my season you
just have this shared bond with each
other and
and cbs is so good at
putting these personalities that thrive
together but also hit heads
so the way that i see it is that i'm not
there for a relationship i'm there to
win
and i'm not going to let something else
distract me
okay well
i would never say never i know you're
there to win i know where your focus is
at but sometimes
when you least expect it that's when the
person comes along
i agree with you but i just i mean since
this is an all-star
there are no all-stars that i have seen
that like i respect their gameplay so
much that if i
had them in the house i'd be like hey
that's no you've literally at some point
seen everybody who could potentially be
in that house so
when you set foot who would are you
for other reasons for alliances for
whatever who are you excited to see
and who are you dreading could possibly
be there
um i mean the only person that i know is
confirmed is me
[Laughter]
thinking about who it could be i i mean
me and josh had such a great
relationship in in my season
i would love to have him there because
he really was a great house guest
and a true friend of mine why he didn't
take me to final two
i get it but i'm still not quite over it
so
you know we'll see how that happens
today if he's there you know
um i i really think about more the
people that i don't want to see
because i just don't like the loud drama
which is funny because josh was so
drama but i got to watch it i don't have
to be in it
and i think about uh you know like
i mean there's just there are lots of
legends if paul came back
i don't really know how i feel about
that because he threw me under the bus
during his
last you know he didn't have to throw me
under the bus all he had to do was
campaign for himself
i remember devin from 16 he was a
nightmare
nightmare
sorry you're not not that cool with evan
and
i think from from my season
raven was also a nightmare sorry raven
like i love you as a person but you are
a nightmare to live with so that is
that is one thing you will hear i think
big brother contestants say probably
more than any other show
i like this person as a person i did not
like them as a player in the house
and there's two different sides of
people um so
you know another thing not only is this
the first all-star season
we've had in years but then on top of it
it's happening in a global pandemic
how will that affect the game i don't
know if
you're a little worried about going in
there with what's happening in the rest
of the world like where's your head at
was this
a tough decision given what's going on
yeah i mean it just one willingly going
into social isolation
already is a hard decision and you have
to prepare yourself for the long game
or you or you just unravel faster than
you do normally because no matter what
you're going to unravel
and for me i had to sit down and really
think about
why i wanted to go in and what it was
going you know the pros and cons of it
was it gonna benefit me more than it
harms my life was i
going to be completely removed i'm like
okay with not knowing what's going on
and honestly even during sequester it's
already been a challenge because you
just
i i haven't been more than a few days
without my son
and then my grandmother just passed uh
two days ago so it's already kind of
like
coming at me but i chose to do this
and i i'm gonna follow through with my
commitment
because it's just it's what i've decided
to do and
it like in the house it's gonna give me
curveballs
and backstabbing and all of the drama
but i signed up for that and so
that's the way that i see it is that i'm
gonna persevere
and i'm gonna trust that if anything
significant happens
they're gonna notify me and that loyal
is in great hands he's gonna have a
great summer with his dad and he's gonna
be able to run around and play
and he has a great community there as
well he's he's
heavily loved i'm so sorry about your
grandmother
thanks you're man um to be
going into this with with that
loss on you already that has to feel big
yes i'm sorry thank you um
so you're going into it uh you you just
mentioned uh
i'm sorry i am i'm sorry
it's uh it's like this crazy thing where
you know you're gonna go and be yourself
and live your life with people but
it's it's i'm sure impossible to forget
the real people in your life who you
might want to be supporting
and it's like 2020 is just so bizarre
it's it's i don't even have words to
describe it every time every time we
turn around something more bizarre
happens
and challenging and i have done a lot of
personal
reflection over the last few years
specifically coming out of the house and
then this year
just amplified it so i mean
with my my granny passing she was 90
she actually the family's a little
relieved because she was suffering a lot
so we know that she's in a better place
and
and i hear her little giggle and she
would be excited for me for this
she she was always interested in the
things that i was doing
well i think you hit the nail on the
head 2020 has been bizarre and all i
keep thinking is
given everything everybody's already
been through this year the way you guys
are heading into
this house this could be the craziest
season ever of big brother i i agree
with you and i think
too that you know since from what i
understand it's an all-star
so i'm guessing that everybody that's
going in the house has already been in
there
either once or twice and there's going
to be a lot more
understanding i think and hopefully
compassion
or i could be totally wrong that's going
to be way more cutthroat
because they just don't give a what
anymore you know who knows
you just gotta it's it's potentially
one or both of them who knows